Sports Illustrated's lead baseball
writer and reporter and MLB Network
analyst Tom Verducci back on the show
how are you Tom I am good on the press
with that knowledge well I'll tell you
what Tom it's it's there's a lot to to
process right now to say the least and I
remember when I was doing you know
filling in for Ravich on Baseball
Tonight doing SportsCenter highlights of
baseball games over and over again
when I was doing it the word juiced ball
was always mentioned and I'm hearing
that for the first time since Tom are
you hearing the same thing oh absolutely
I've been hearing it all year long
especially now that the weather is
warming up you see it and hear it a lot
but I'll go back to the unity of the
season when the ball was really carrying
cold weather it caught people's
attention a couple of things have caught
my eye Ridge number one I'm paying
attention to outfielders route and every
night I'm constantly seeing outfielders
taking a path where they think the ball
should be and then they have to go to
plan B and veer off and go deeper
because the ball is carrying of course
that's just anecdotally but if you want
some data with the help of stat cast
which has been around for three years
looking at 450 home runs I know about
you rich but it seems like every night
I'm seeing some home run that just
ridiculously go in places that other
balls don't go and it's true I mean the
last two years 450 foot home runs have
gone up about 26%
that's an enormous jump in a short
period of time so I'm not a conspiracy
theorist I don't think that people got
together in some dark room and said hey
let's juice the baseball but I think
something is up at the baseball whether
it's the way it's manufactured with the
way it's stored I just I think it has to
be something to it because we don't have
anything else in play not expansion
there's no recognition that the ball is
different the bats are pretty much the
same and the first thing you go to is
baseball well that's the first thing
let's go to that first thing then how's
this landing in Major League Baseball's
front office's and the and the
Commissioner's Office Tom well listen
this is actually really started the
second half of 2015 season that's when
it really started jump I've never seen
it in season jump like that that was so
obvious it carried into last year I
thought it would level off but it
continues to go up and up so I you know
baseball wanted more offense if you go
back to the halfway point of the 15
season we are at about a ten-year trust
or offense in the game pitching was
really dominating and there's a lot of
talk about what can we do to juice
massive ball literally and put the game
that's when they started talking about
raising the strike zone get the ball
play more and now it looks like maybe
the ball is overcooked because what
you're doing now in baseball is you are
constantly defending the home run we
don't see rallies this is the record in
terms of home run rate percentage of
runs scored on home runs and if you want
to throw in the strikeouts which keep
going up and certainly your guy
Bellinger is a good example of this now
one out of every three trips to the
plate in beige leagues
you don't need defense that's a
strikeout a walk or a home run you know
I used to play stickball with my
brothers me too elementary school yes
strikes all with a tennis ball a
broomstick you didn't need defense right
that's what major league baseball is
becoming homerun strikeout
walk well I mean I so you're saying with
my stickball experience I've got a
chance at age 47 about to be 48 times
every time baseball alert for you it
took a while but it's finally here so I
finally got a chance like a dumb and
Dumberer chance Tom Verducci joining me
here on the show but let's go a little
bit deeper the first thing you look at
is the ball but I also remember when the
when the juice ball era was being
discussed we found out the players were
juiced as well and what about that
conversation is there anything going on
21st century style that the league is
looking into or not about that
something that might not being might not
be caught with a with a urine test or
anything like that Tom well yeah I mean
the idea that baseball could eradicate
peds in the game it's just naive but
never going to happen with the money at
stake with the scarcity of jobs that are
available you're always going to have
guys looking for an edge I will say in
the last three years and testing really
has advanced very far that's very much
harder to beat the test the way the guys
were say with the biogenesis Clank
that doesn't mean guys aren't using I
still hear a lot of talk among the
players themselves about hey this guy
must be on something again I don't think
players know sure
people just don't talk about it and
broadcast anymore like they did back in
a day but I think to a certain level and
all you have to do is look at the
minor-league numbers especially where
the positive rates really haven't gone
down at all that there's still a
temptation yes I don't think that's an
easy explanation for home runs in the
game I'm just saying that will always be
there but testing is stricter based on
what you could tell African they test
more and it is more sophisticated in
fact a lot of guys have gotten up in the
last couple of years using drugs that
previously you could need to test with
but now they're picking up metabolites
of drugs not necessarily a drug themself
in other words the markers for those
drugs are being caught in tests Tom
Verducci joining us here on the Rich
Eisen show let's check out the American
League here with you right now
the Yankees cooled off the West Coast
certainly cooled them off they've lost
six in a row going into tonight's game
home date with the Angels
and then you take a look in the American
League West the Astros have played about
500 ball for three weeks now and the
hottest team in the Kansas City Royals
coming on strong what is your take on
the American League right now Tom what
it's an absolute free-for-all there's
nobody that's out of it I think the
Oakland A's at the worst record of
baseball heading into yesterday and they
were only four and a half games out of a
playoff spot so good luck trying to find
sellers at the trade deadline in the
American League and that includes Kansas
City you know I've been tired of people
ever since last December when the CBA
was signed talking about the dismantling
of the Kansas City Royals is they have
so many players that I need a free agent
here this is still a good team with a
pedigree that knows how to win it's a
good baseball town they say so a lot of
tickets in advance they are not pulling
the plug on this season unless they're
hopelessly out of it I mean like really
out of it July and that doesn't look
like it's going to happen so they're
going to play it out with the team they
have now Yankees started 21 and 9
obviously they weren't that good but I
still think they're a contending team
they've more found their level and you
said to me is still the best team in the
league tracked affect in terms of the
rosters now they're vulnerable right now
because they have for their starting
pitchers on the DL
they're going to start to get those guys
back Keiko McCullers Morton McHugh will
start coming back between now and the
all-star break
I don't worry about them at all here's
why the way I look at the cup the Astros
did like the Cubs last year Cubs are the
best team in the National League but
they knew to win the World Series
not just to make the playoffs they had a
big hole when it came to their bullpen
and they went and got Chapman I feel
that way about the Astros team the
league but to win it for the first time
in Houston they need to go get
themselves a left-handed reliever and a
starting pitcher and I think they will
and you mentioned the Cubs my bad also
two Indians fans they want their teams
won six in a row so we're beginning to
see the Indians get their championship
sea legs a little bit underneath them
what about the Cubs it seems that
they're just keep that they just can't
put their foot in the dirt and finally
gain some traction this year Tom I agree
and you know I've seen a lot of them in
recently and I'll be honest with you I
don't like what I see
I thought they would start slow because
Joe Maddon smartly so slow play two
starting pitchers in spring training
after pitching the 7th month and really
pushing them last year that made sense
you figure they get out of the gate slow
but now we're creeping up on half of the
season and I don't like the way they're
playing defense but kind of back on
their heels a little bit sloppy I don't
think they pay as much attention to
detail I think they really miss David
Ross not so much the clubhouse fit but
the way he runs cares for games
remember Wilson Contreras extremely
talented but when it comes to calling
games he is still pretty much a rookie
doesn't have a lot of experience he's
converted infielder so I see a lot of
things with the Cubs that go beyond just
hey they have a hangover for winning
last year I really don't think that's it
I just think they've earned where
they're at right now they've played
mediocre baseball and that's what the
record shows and unlike the American
League the National League wild card is
essentially toast like you you you
better win your division which is not
good news for the National League East
because in the National League West the
Rockies and Diamondbacks are no flukes
and they are have the same number of
losses as the Dodgers right now all
three teams as we're talking right now
have 26 losses how how good do you think
these the Rockies are Tom with the
Diamondbacks here I like the Rockies a
lot I picked them as a wild-card team
before the season
because there's so athletic dynamic
offense and I thought it all hinged on
their bullpens which I thought just
needed to be mediocre and they're beyond
mediocre they're really really good now
they do have a lot of young pitchers
that may wear down in the second half
but I think they have enough of an
inventory to cover the inevitable
regression by some of those young
pitchers Arizona's is a surprise to me I
think they're a year ahead of where I
thought they would be that's a credit to
Torrey lobello and Mike Hayes in the new
GM I love what they did when they
brought it just Mathis and Chris
Iannetta they prioritize defense behind
the plate and what you're seeing now is
the residue in pitching they're starting
pitching is the best and National League
and I really didn't see that coming like
I said it's come together really quickly
just legend people at home offensively
so yeah I would say both of those teams
are absolutely legitimate and it's
Ortiz's farewell on Friday night where I
guess Pitt will that finally quick event
that he's not coming back for the Red
Sox no matter what Pedro says about his
conditioning it's that over time let's
finally put it to bed what do you think
yeah finally we can put it again and
people don't realize how beat up Big
Papi was last year I mean his feet legs
were absolutely killing it took a lot
just to get on the field and once you're
his age and your body's beat up like
that and you shut it down it's just way
too hard to just reboot it so it's a
nice thought he's probably one of these
guys who could wake up Christmas Eve and
go out and hit a rope off the monster
but it ain't happening
Tom thanks for the time always enjoy
chatting with you nice roots like them
and you bet it's Tom Verducci of MLB
Network the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on radio stations across
the country
and audience
isn't it amazing you can download an app
with your thumbprint you should download
our app with your thumbprint